then I read my third script that I got  my hand on and it was Walter Hill's  script for his first movie as a director  hard times and I had seen the movie a  bunch of times by that point but when I  read hard times then I could see what a  script could be it was exciting it was  fun and it wasn't just the dialogue and  it wasn't just description it was prose  now not prose like I'm used to in a  novel but it was a prose that was  appropriate for a screenplay he he  wasn't just giving a blueprint for how a  bunch of technicians can make this movie  later like a recipe for a cake that  somebody else is going to bake the prose  was written for me the reader I was  supposed to get caught up into this I  was supposed to be excited about this  story I was supposed to get caught up in  the story and even more importantly I  was supposed to make the movie in my  mind when the script was over and I put  it down I saw it I saw the movie  [Applause]